Heil Heil labrat he'll steal mother hail  mother [ __ ] a dog is not human it's an  animal Nature doesn't care about them  it's sad but true  we're a dogs only friend a wiener dog  she looks like you  Thanks no no hi Oh tomorrow come on come  along  what's it Ohio crystal meth okay this is  fancy fantasy is an artist Nana used to  do some painting I posed nude didn't  spread my legs it's cool you need to  exercise I walk my dog exercise  I can't you gotta have a what if what if  you taught the script writing at a film  someone had no talent  these are the great that you have a new  dog what's its name  cancer why would your name it uh it felt  right  what time